Bienvenidos a reporteros el magacín de
los grandes reportajes de la redacción
de France 24 soy herminia Fernández
comenzamos
tras 70 años de amenazas chinas Taiwán
nunca ha estado bajo tanta presión las
tensiones en torno a Taiwán son
posiblemente Las mayores de 1949
Taiwán una isla de 23 millones de
habitantes a 128 kilómetros de la costa
de China ha sido durante mucho tiempo
una fuente de tensión entre Washington y
Pekín China reclama a Taiwán una isla
gobernada democráticamente como parte de
su territorio y ha prometido tomarla a
través del uso de la fuerza de ser
necesario en términos de fuerza militar
china es superior a Taiwán en casi todos
los aspectos sin embargo Taiwán tiene
una mayor reserva militar de tropas
terrestres que ha entrenado para el caso
de una invasión a gran escala durante
casi tres semanas los perio de France 24
se sumergieron en la vida cotidiana de
habitantes de Taiwán de jóvenes
políticos en campaña y de un
multimillonario belicista para
comprender sus preocupaciones y
esperanzas en torno a este conflicto
aquí la historia
[Música]
es el día de la fiesta nacional en
taipei el gobierno de la República china
celebra los 111 años de un pequeño
estado que nunca antes en su historia
reciente había estado bajo la presión de
la invasión militar la acusada está aquí
arde entre Pekín y Taiwán y el mundo
aguanta la respiración
la comunidad internacional lo ha
entendido perfectamente reforzar la
seguridad de Taiwán significa también
reforzar y garantizar la paz regional y
los valores de la Democracia la
destrucción de la Democracia taiwanesa
sería un fracaso terrible para las
libertades y las democracias mundiales
proteger nuestro territorio defender
nuestra nación
no puede ser y no será nunca una
responsabilidad única del ejército
Cada ciudadano es el protector de la
nación
Qué representa todo eso para usted señor
no tiene ningún sentido tal como para
más de la mitad de los 23 millones de
taiwaneses Chen es un ferviente defensor
de la independencia Bueno hoy en día el
asunto de nuestra independencia es
importante mi país está siendo amenazado
y para mí esto prevalece sobre los
asuntos políticos debemos primero
proteger Taiwán es la prioridad número
uno
sueña con vivir en la República de
Taiwán a pesar de los discursos
marciales de la presidenta este día le
reprocha al gobierno no ser más ofensivo
ante Pekín
Este zapato es la presión china sobre
nosotros lo que quiere decir y lo pienso
también por supuesto
es que nosotros en Taiwán estamos
aplastados constantemente por China
la guerra de Taiwán tendrá lugar china
bajo el impulso del presidente se
lanzará en su proyecto hegemónico de
reunificación la reunificación un
contrasentido histórico para los
taiwaneses que nunca se han sentido tan
pocos chinos en la medida en que los
preparativos de un conflicto amenazan su
isla
la defensa de Taiwán se volvió
justamente la obsesión de este hombre
joven una de las fortunas más grandes de
la isla una fortuna que decidió poner al
servicio de lo que dominar la
resistencia a la opresión de Pekín
acabo de publicar un artículo donde doy
las claves para que la opinión esté más
implicada en el asunto de la
independencia de Taiwán frente a China
creo que es importante en este momento
sugiero también que deberíamos empezar
por cambiar de nombre no llamarnos
República de China sino simplemente
Taiwán
nos llamamos china también
ello genera confusión me entiende y es
un asunto de seguridad nacional
Hay que ser claros somos un estado
independiente pero qué le responde usted
Robert a sus detractores a quienes le
reprochan de ir muy lejos con este tipo
de discurso
son unos cobardes le tienen miedo a
China
temen que si cambiamos de nombre China
se enfade etcétera
Qué es una provocación
pero no es solamente una manera de
aclarar la situación
Nosotros somos una nación y lo somos
desde hace cientos de años
y ellos debe ser reconocido por el mundo
entero nos reunimos
en el 2019 lo empujó a comprometer
millones de dólares en la preparación de
los taiwaneses para la invasión teórica
por ahora del vecino
sabe la gente aquí es muy Serena
Tal vez
porque han escuchado tantas veces esta
historia del lobo que atacaba
y no lo han visto
los taiwaneses están como paralizados
y ellos mientras la propaganda china ha
invadido los medios aquí
venía
y el mensaje es que cualquier forma de
defensa de Taiwán es inútil
en vísperas de las elecciones locales se
unió a la juventud de la política
taiwanesa
lean junín hace parte de los candidatos
una forma de recusar la política
tradicional taiwanesa cuya línea es el
frágil status quo con Pekín porque se
metió en política porque nuestra
generación debe entender que debemos de
tener imperativamente toda forma de
dependencia de China
[Música]
nuestra plataforma se basa en la defensa
de nuestros valores democráticos y
estamos Unidos para resistir a cualquier
forma de agresión externa como La
amenaza de Invasión china
Todos hemos visto lo que ocurrió en
Ucrania hubo una movilización general en
las ciudades y en las zonas Rurales
contra la invasión rusa los ucranianos
eligieron vivir y morir su padre debemos
hacer lo mismo actualmente los
taiwaneses deben tener representantes
políticos cuya prioridad sea reforzar
las alianzas con los países amigos
contra el enemigo del extranjero
joven está por todas partes en los
diarios En estudios de televisión tal
como en este programa de debate popular
todo el mundo sabe aquí que sus ideas y
su influencia prosperarán en la opinión
taiwanesa
[Música]
Robert es muy importante para nosotros
es una fuente de inspiración para la
población
porque refuerza nuestra determinación
a título personal y agradezco por todo
lo que hace lo que le entrega a Taiwán
[Aplausos]
[Música]
he aquí la pequeña isla de la hipotética
línea de frente de esta guerra de Taiwán
que todo el mundo teme y que nadie sabe
si tendrá lugar aquí china popular está
menos de 2 km los rascacielos y los 5
millones de habitantes de la ciudad
costera de chamín dan una idea de la
reacción de fuerzas es extraño casi
excitante estar aquí tan cerca y poder
ver tan claramente China desde aquí no
da miedo no porque estamos Unidos a
China en nuestras vidas lo queramos sí o
no la guerra Por supuesto que le tememos
la Paz es un valor universal no
pero hasta ahora china Nunca ha querido
renunciar a dominar Taiwán de fuerza
para Pekín es un asunto de hegemonía
de supremacía militar tal como una
enésima referencia a Ucrania la
denominan la crimea de Taiwán es el
puesto de Avanzada más expuesto ubicado
del lado chino del estrecho es así
estamos en esta pequeña Isla frente al
continente chino desde hace siglos no
podemos hacer nada para cambiar nuestra
posición geográfica mi país es una
democracia liberal Mientras que el otro
lado como lo sabemos es un estado
compartido único un estado autoritario
la libertad de expresión y de creencias
la existencia de los partidos políticos
están prohibidos
creo que vivir donde estoy no me hace
menos feliz que vivir en China
continental
regresó a taipe Incluso en lo más alto
del estado se dice que hay que
prepararse para lo peor que piensa usted
un hombre como Robert South su
compromiso es importante
de Taiwán cuando usted mira lo que
ocurre en Ucrania
ya no es solo responsabilidad del
gobierno
si la población es formada con equipos y
conocimientos para defender su país
creo que china estará frente a graves
problemas en caso de ataque
Entonces en cuanto a Robert sus ideas y
sus generosas ayudas solo podemos
impulsarlas
los civiles taiwaneses en la escuela de
guerra
actualmente miles atienden estas
formaciones financiadas por Robert Saw
quien pretende movilizar una fuerza de
defensa civil de 300.000 voluntarios
estoy aquí para estar listo para la
guerra Quiero saber cuáles Serán las
medidas de China si nos ataca este curso
es esencial para nosotros Porque es
necesario que los taiwaneses sepan que
china es nuestra enemiga los chinos Ya
empezaron la guerra de la información y
muchos taiwaneses no conocen la verdad
nos reunimos con Chen el militante por
la independencia de Taiwán vive en el
barrio One ua al sur de taipei con sus
dos hijas y su esposa profesora de
francés
Taiwán hace parte de China la doctrina
comunista explota la confusión histórica
y se volvió un compromiso internacional
los Estados Unidos apoyan nuestra
democracia pero no dicen que apoyan la
independencia de Taiwán dicen que no se
oponen creo que nosotros debemos elegir
elegir entre la independencia o no
nuestros amigos nos dicen
somos taiwaneses pero también chinos
porque somos sentimentalmente cercanos a
los chinos
pero de hecho solo tenemos un país
Taiwán
[Música]
los primeros Rastros de ocupación humana
de Taiwán se remontan a más de 30.000
años mientras esta cuna de la población
asiática y de Oceanía vive actualmente
Bajo La amenaza de uno de los ejércitos
más potentes del planeta los taiwaneses
siguen viviendo preparándose para la
guerra
hasta aquí reporteros de la semana
recuerda que para sintonizar esta y las
emisiones anteriores puede visitar
nuestro sitio web France 24.com hasta la
próxima
[Música]